dangerous heat wave scorching much of
the country has turned deadly more than
a hundred and three million Americans
are under heat alerts the extreme heat
will blanket a huge section of the
country today stretching from the
Midwest into the Northeast high
temperatures are expected to soar into
the 90s in many cities and it will feel
like triple digit heat in places like
Louisville Charleston and
Charlottesville Virginia at least three
deaths two in New York and one in
Pennsylvania are being blamed on the
extreme heat that started last Friday
Jericka Duncan is at Jones Beach on New
York's Long Island where a huge crowd
will try to stay cool Jericka good
morning good morning you know this to be
is the best time to be here on the beach
it is quiet
it feels great but I can tell you before
the fourth of July fireworks people
thousands of them will be working to
stay cool here at Jones Beach they're
expecting temperatures to feel like 96
degrees here later today and while there
are no cooling shelters in this area
it's a different story elsewhere across
the country hundreds of people in Boston
said under the hot Sun through
temperatures that reach the mid 90s to
watch a pre-holiday concert
the heat index made it feel closer to
105 so fans took precautions we stayed
in the shade and drank a lot of water
hydrate hydrate and a little bit more
hydrate this has been the hottest
stretch above 90 degrees locally since
2013
in Addison Texas just north of Dallas at
least three people attending a holiday
festival were taken to the hospital for
heat related emergencies many others
were treated on the scene and released
rehydrated fresh rain oh watch the
fireworks in New York volunteers with
meals on wheels deliver 18,000 meals
every day making a point to knock on
doors especially during extreme weather
like this today during this ultra hot
stretch they are paying even closer
attention to how the heat is affecting
the elderly the city's office of
emergency management says seniors are
one of the group's at an increased risk
of heat related health issues today two
other deaths are being investigated in
Kansas City possibly because of the heat
of course if you do not have an air
conditioning the best way to stay cool
one of the best ways of course come to
the beach or of course take a dip in the
pool officials here at Jones Beach tell
us that more than a half a million
people have come here since the heat
wave started on Friday
Jericka thank you find some find some
shade find an umbrella my friend